really concerning issue there's arisen
in the last months concerns historical
ago she's a child abusive from your
reaction when you started hearing these
stories from play well as anybody would
it's it's terrible it's horrible the
idea that that would happen in a
sporting context in a football context
that young people who were confronted
with those with those with those things
happening and of course our first
reaction is feeling sorry for those
people that have beat were victims or
they as we would say survivors those
horrible things but as a professional
you then have to say right you know we
absolutely must make sure double check
recheck that everything we are doing now
is you know clearly it's a different era
and we have been shaoling a 2016 light
on 1970s 80's 90's practices i've been
around a long time
I was certainly around when we started
to improve procedures we call it child
protection back then with the FAA and
the NSPCC advising us and all working
together to make sure we had policies in
place both at our academies and within
communities and community areas and of
course that's the most important thing
are we safeguarding our young people
today and I absolutely am confident not
complacent that we have the right
schemes and the right policies in place
and we take this extremely seriously the
club's taking enormous just you know in
with enormous seriousness but there is
no room for complacency Chris at any
point you know these these things can
incidents can happen then therefore
that's obviously what we're
concentrating our efforts on right now
the FA obviously and the police quite
rightly they're going back to look at
those historic cases and see what should
be done and also everybody's doing their
own review we're doing our own review
even even though yeah within our own
offices and all the clubs are actually
you know going back and making sure
double checking and rechecking to make
sure policies and procedures are in
place to make sure nothing like this
should ever happen and that's why you
know we could you know we could do risk
all this we could do risk all this play
not getting involved in young people but
just not you know doing anything for for
community we're not coming in to these
to these areas with these young people
but that would be that would be terrible
that'd be the last thing we want to
and what we want to do is be able to do
more of this kind of thing and therefore
the safeguarding aspects as they are now
are vitally important to all that one
Premier League club has done itself
Chelsea and use of confidentiality
clause with one perform victim
controversial do you think that was an
appropriate I'm involved in that from
her from obviously from it from another
perspective from a regulatory
perspective I'm not going to go on
national media in comment about that we
are looking though obviously we would
there will be consequences all clubs are
being referenced in in any in any
reports of abuse we'll have to go back
and look at their look at what happened
at the time it quite difficult but
obviously very few records obviously not
near the employees mostly a lot of them
dead certainly no longer employed by the
clubs again it's all all difficult but
it has to be done and we have to go back
and the clubs are all come back and
check and then when all the data from
all these inquiries and everything comes
forward we will have to deal
appropriately with it then but it will
be rolling me to comment on any
individual certainly one case went to
convictions nope
nothing at all nothing at all don't
we're dealt with by the authorities and
the chart if equality ain't just come in
and therefore but certainly when we
started to get involved when I started
get involved at the Premier League in in
99 2000 obviously Child Protection and
safeguarding was there was new law new
changes and we worked very hard to make
sure that all the safeguarding
procedures were put in place then but
initially nothing it's got a sign of the
times perhaps yeah I don't think I don't
think these things were no they just
weren't they just weren't out there in
the way as I say we are shining a 2006
night and quite rightly we are shining a
2016 light on what happened a long time
ago but doesn't mean to say we shouldn't
shine on it because that's the way you
learn but you learn from history to make
sure you're you're well equipped to deal
with now in the future